Well,
my suspicion is that people are not
really,
at least in all cases,
more motivated by economic concerns than
other concerns.
What I suspect is that people think they
have to talk in economic terms.
They have to provide economic
justifications for things that they
actually want to do for other sorts of
considerations.
And I'll just give you a few examples of
that.
They're really a grab bag of examples of
people.
People did not go into the streets
ultimately to overthrow communism in
1989 in eastern Europe because they did
some kind of benefit cost analysis and
decided that the risk of being run over
by a Soviet tank with somehow less than
the benefit they might gain if there was
a transition to a capitalist economy.
I mean,
they did this out of a,
out of a sense of idealism,
out of a sense of the dignity of a,
of individual people that was being
trampled in these kinds of societies and
out of a vision of what a better world
could be.
They didn't do it in economic terms.
Um,
similarly today,
in the last decade in American society,
there are people who favor a policy that
I very much disagree with,
that's known as the war on drugs.
The war on drugs is not an economically
rational policy,
and even people who support the war on
drugs would not argue for it and
economic grounds.
They argue for it on moral grounds that
it's wrong for people to take drugs.
It's wrong for society to send a message
that says that it's okay to do that.
So I think generally we do still often
act out of non economic motives.
It's just that like those people in the
16th century,
somehow we think we need to defend those
actions.
Now on the basis of economics.
Then on the basis of religion,
I think one of the hopeful signs is that
President Obama is beginning to bring
back a richer and fuller.
And ultimately what I think is a more
realistic and more human kind of
rhetoric to our political debates.
There are many issues in American public
life that,
that divide people and interesting and
somewhat unpredictable way.
So there are people,
often people associated with the
political right who say that we should,
you should only do things that make
sense economically and what is all this
nonsense that environmentalist want to
do to lock up wilderness areas and so
on.
But then when it comes to issues like a
outlying drugs outlawing abortion range
of other issues,
they're the ones who are taking moral
positions.
They're not taking hardheaded sort of
libertarian a positions based on
economic realities.
None of us are rational economic man as
we're supposed to be portrayed in
economic,
were mixes of passions,
of,
of desires,
of a moral principles,
of,
of self,
deception,
of altruism,
of concern for others,
concerned for ourselves and an interest
in our bank.
Accounts and social policies have to be
responsive to the complexity of who we
are as people or else like the war on
drugs.
They're simply going to fail.
I think one reason we fetishize
economics is because we have come to
think that it is essentially connected
to wellbeing about what it is to have a
good life.
And in fact,
there's very little psychological
evidence for this being a very strong
relationship.
Um,
if you look at the work psychologists
have done with the individual reports of
wellbeing,
what happens is that if you're poor,
you are not happy,
but once you achieve a certain level of
material satisfaction,
um,
then income has very little correlation
with people's report.
It states of happiness,
things like climate matter,
more things like the,
the culture of the country in which
you're raised matter more.
And so two things really,
let's face it,
like individual temperament matter,
matter more than these things.
So once we see that economics is to a
very great extent,
detached from what it is that really
give us quality of life,
that can be a very liberating sort of
insight,
um,
because what that means is,
and this,
this sound very unpopular at this
moment,
but an economic downturn with all of the
damage and real damage that,
that creates,
may not make us as unhappy as we might
imagine.
And indeed it might create opportunities
for new ways of life,
for new forms of happiness,
for new ideas of quality of life that we
simply would not have seen,
uh,
when we were in the world of getting
richer and richer and richer and richer
without any reflection whatsoever.
Now,
the Millennium Development Goals are
important,
both morally and economically because
much of the world's population maybe as
much as a third of the world's
population,
hasn't yet reached the level of economic
development where we began to get a
dissociation from people's economic
status and their reports about personal
happiness.
So we really do need to do much more and
much more effectively in order to give
everyone the kind of basis for for which
they can have good lives.